If you want to hear how the real life form
of Valak has a cameo in the deleted scenes
of The Nun, then stick around to the end of
this video.
[Intro]
Welcome back to Things You Missed, and welcome
to the end of the 👏 year as we know it.
One of the most hyped events of the 👏 year
for horror was the release of the fifth Conjurverse
film, The Nun.
There were controversies, there were theories,
there was speculation.
And then the movie came out and no one really
liked it, BUT.... they didn't see the deleted
scenes.
Until very recently, when they were released.
And I have 'em.
And there are a couple more connections to
the Conjuring franchise and other Things You
Missed in these deleted scenes, so let's do
the part where I tell them to you.
OK, the first deleted scene shows Father Burke
before he gets called to the Vatican, and
he's in Philadelphia sitting in the confession
booth listening to this young boy named Timothy
makes his confessions.
As a side note, I have to wonder if the reason
this scene got cut had anything to do with
that huge scandal with the priests in Philadelphia
that happened this year, probably right around
the time this movie was being finished.
You know, the thing I should never talk about
in detail if I ever want to be considered
for YouTube Rewind?
Anyway, in this scene, Father Burke is doing
his crossword puzzles, as he's seen doing
throughout the Nun, however, this is a different
puzzle from the one he carries in Romania
during the rest of the film.
The word that comes to him is "crow", foreshadowing
one of the first things he sees at the Abbey,
a flock of crows.
Remember when they're in the carriage later
on the way to the Abbey, Sister Irene helps
him come up with the word, "deliveries", which
foreshadows them going to the delivery room
-- I have to wonder if him coming up with
the word "crow" could be a hint that Father
Burke has a little sliver of psychic abilities
as well.
One of the other words he has written
is Bobby Thomson, former Cub, just saying.
There's also an extension of the scene where
Father Burke first meets Sister Irene.
He tells her to pack civilian clothes, because
this will be one occasion in which they don't
want to broadcast their faith.
Again, it makes me wonder if Father Burke senses
there is something evil there already, and
he wants to stay a little bit incognito during
their approach.
After Father Burke and Sister Irene discover
the books, there's a deleted of the Father
first taking a look at them, where we can
also see some kind of mask?
It kind of reminds me of the Sunny Family
Cult mask from Crypt TV.
Sister Irene asks why they don't just destroy
the books, and this is the Father's response.
"There's a belief in certain circles that
destroying any object with magic could release
whatever power is believed to be stowed inside."
This is a reference to Ed Warren's belief
that he explains in the Conjuring as the reason
they lock all of their cursed objects up in
a room.
"Well why not just throw them in an incinerator?"
"Destroying them would only destroy the vessel.
Sometimes it's better to keep the genie in
the bottle."
I would speculate these books from the Abbey
could eventually make their way into the Warren's
room of cursed objects.
The father also further explains something
I brought up in the previous episodes on The
Nun, which was this symbol of the snake eating
its tail.
I had mentioned that the snake is a reference
to Valak, who is known as The Marquis of Snakes,
and the father adds that the snake consuming
itself represents the cycle of death and rebirth.
Now remember there were also sightings of
this symbol, but with the snakes in a figure-8
like an infinity symbol.
This might be a hint that Valak will keep
being reborn continuously, thus becoming a
recurring villain in the series.
Also in the previous episode, I pointed out
the big hidden detail that connects Lorraine
Warren to Sister Irene's past.
Click here if you want to see it.
One of the other pieces of evidence that contributes
to their connection was the fact that the
Vatican sends Sister Irene to Romania because
of her familiarity with the territory.
But she's never been to Romania, so I speculated
that the reason for sending her was because
her visions and family connection to Lorraine
Warren.
That's all basically confirmed in this deleted
scene.
"Territory.
Colonel Conroy recommended you because you
were familiar with the territory.
He didn't mean Romania, he meant your visions.
Sister, you are familiar with strange phenomenon."
The next one doesn't really have any Things
You Missed, so let's move onto my favorite
of the the deleted scenes.
Because it's the creepiest.
This is after Irene wakes up in the Abbey
and she's looking around.
Last time one of the things I pointed out
was Valak's ability to create wind even in
an enclosed hallway.
Here we can see that it's definitely more
than a coincidence.
Roll it.
Let me know in the comments if you notice
any unexplained indoor wind in any of the
other films, there could be references to
Valak that we haven't uncovered yet.
If you've been following my Things You Missed
coverage of The Nun, you'll know that Valak
is based off of a demon known as the President
of Hell, as told in the real-life book, The
Lesser Key of Solomon.
In that book, Valak is described as an angelically
winged boy riding a two-headed dragon, attributed
with the power of finding treasures.
The Nun form of Valak is actually something
that's unique to The Conjuring movies, and
when I saw these demon-like forms in the texts
found by Father Burke, I speculated that Valak
has the ability to change among many forms.
This scene where all the Nuns are praying
is extended to confirm my suspicions.
"It takes many forms.
A serpent.
A small child.
A demon.
But the form the evil takes the most is..."
"A nun!"
Someone in the comments also pointed out that
the demon form of Valak can be seen briefly
at the end of The Conjuring 2, and I mentioned
in the previous Nun episode that the child
form is not seen, but referenced briefly when
this statue suddenly has wings.
The Nuns also go onto explain to Sister Irene
that The Abyss lost her life and soul going
up against Valak.
When I first saw the Nun I had assumed that
most of the Nun spirits she encounters at
they Abbey are manifestations of Valak, but
with the addition of this scene, I'd say that
most of them are there to help her, and the
Abyss is possibly the only one she encounters
that's being controlled by Valak.
Our last deleted scene has Sister Irene questioning
what will happen if the evil re-emerges, and
Father Burke assures her that someone good
will be there to send it back if that does
happen, which foreshadows the actions that
Lorraine Warren would later take in The Conjuring
2.
The holidays may be over but, you're still
gonna want to start 2019 off in style, and
here's how you do it.
Go to the CZsWorld merch store and use code
'DEATHMAS' for 10% off any of these stylish
designs for the rest of the month.
But most importantly, we're gonna be getting
a new chapter in The Conjuring Universe this
summer, so if you want to hear all the Things
You Missed in Annabelle 3, remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I'll
see you in the next year.
Assuming we both survive.